avec nous maintenant Clément Gignac
économiste sénateur indépendant qu'on
retrouve à Ottawa bonsoir Clément Gignac
bonsoir alors de 20 à 40% de plus en
paiement hypothécaire puis peut-être
même plus encore est-ce que c'est
inquiétant ça mais c'est inquiétant
certainement pour les ménages qui ont
acheté une maison sur la fin de la
pandémie avant que les taux d'intérêt
augmentent parce que là il bénéficieront
pas de nos prix de la maison parce qu'on
sent en doute acheter au sommet et là
ils n'ont pas encore connu qu'est-ce que
c'est la rose et versements hypothécaire
quand andréan parle de hausse qui
pourrait atteindre entre 25 et 40%
surtout c'est un jeune ménage commence
dans la vie il y a pas beaucoup de
capital de côté donc je dirais que c'est
pas mal pour moins de 5% des ménages qui
vont être plus en difficulté financière
mais ça va faire mal parce que des
hausses comme ça ça a été très très
rapide et donc c'est pas tout le monde
qui est capable de se relever oui donc
ça m'inquiète un peu oui oui c'est ça
essayant de mesurer l'ampleur la
sous-gouverneur Caroline Rogers a dit
aujourd'hui que la situation sera
gérable pour la majorité des gens mais
il faut quand même il faut quand même
s'habituer à payer plus cher là et être
dans un environnement de taux d'intérêt
plus élevé l'emploi demeure très robuste
également donc ça ne va pas ébranler les
colonnes du temple financier mais une
portion de la phrase qui est importante
aussi longtemps que l'emploi se porte
bien passé la variable la plus
importante si vous gardez votre emploi
votre ce moment-là oui vous allez
peut-être réajuster vos dépenses elle
est peut-être aller au restaurant moins
souvent reporter un voyage mais aussi
longtemps que le marché du travail se
porte bien c'est pas trop inquiétant
mais si jamais la Banque du Canada
poursuivait des hausses de taux
d'intérêt parce que l'inflation se
réaccélère de nouveau qu'autre chose
genre et connaître une récession là ça
serait vraiment beaucoup plus difficile
je répète c'est surtout pour les jeunes
ménages ou les ménages en général qui
ont acheté une maison sur la fin de la
pandémie et là qui ont payé et en
bénéficie des taux très faibles ça va
être plus difficile marcher du travail
très important et c'est pour ça que je
pense la bande du Canada va qui est déjà
sur les lignes de côté il va y passer
deux fois avant de réaugmenter taux
d'intérêt la lumière du rapport qui ont
déposé aujourd'hui donc on a
l'immigration on a la rareté des
inscriptions dans le marché immobilier
ça garde quand même le marché immobilier
sous tension en ce moment les prix
recommencent à monter les prix de
l'immobilier mais surtout à Toronto et
avant couvert l'inflation qui reste
autour de 4% et là des versements qui
vont exploser dans les prochaines années
est-ce que la santé financière générale
des ménages va se détériorer est-ce
qu'on peut dire ça avec un impact à la
clé sur l'économie la réponse c'est oui
parce que là bon faut pas prendre les
deux trois derniers mois parce que c'est
pas vraiment une tendance les prix sont
quand même ont descendu par rapport au
sommet évidemment l'immigration tient
quand même des nouveaux des prêts élevés
au Canada donc la situation des ménages
est encore très très saine au moment où
on par contre ça va devenir plus
difficile plus qu'on avait avancé
puisque vous l'avez dit il y a juste le
tiers des ménages qui ont connu
qu'est-ce que c'est des hausses de taux
d'intérêt donc le gros s'en vient et là
ce moment-là à moins que les salaires
suivent et ça sera pas le cas pour tout
le monde quand on parle de hausse et
versements de 25 à 40 % donc oui
l'immobilier on revoit une hausse mais
je pense que c'est plutôt temporaire le
rebond qu'on ne
c'est ce que je crois du moins là est-ce
que est-ce que Clémence je vais vous
entendre là-dessus Desjardins parle
d'une possibilité de récession
immobilière
donc avec des ménages qui vont être
obligés de mettre toute leur épargne par
exemple sur leur paiement hypothécaire
un peu comme en 1990 qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette possibilité je partage
l'opinion de Desjardins sur le mot qu'on
aura une récession économique mais je ne
partage pas sur la récession immobilière
pourquoi parce qu'en 90 si on regarde
actuellement la croissance de la
population au Canada allez trois fois
plus rapide qu'en 1990 une des raisons
c'est que les migration est beaucoup
plus forte donc une récession
immobilière oui il y aura une récession
mais ça sera pas une dépression
économique ni immobilière donc un recul
des prix oui un recul de l'activité
économique mais aussi longtemps qu'on
maintient des taux d'immigration des
niveaux des migration aussi élevés je
doute qu'on est un repli du côté de
l'immobilier comment on a connu au début
des années 90 Caroline Rogers donc là
dessus la sous-gouverneur a dit aussi
qui est pas question de permettre un
amortissement plus long pour les
nouveaux emprunteurs mais qui tirait la
période de remboursement deviendra quand
même avantageux pour plusieurs ménages
et environ 30% des emprunteurs de 4
institutions financières du Canada qui
échelonnent déjà leurs emprunts sur 30
ans est-ce qu'on va aller davantage vers
30 ans pour beaucoup de ménages selon
vous beaucoup de ménage d'accord avec ma
ce gouverneur à l'effet que pour on
commencera pas à mettre systématiquement
là pour étaler à 35 quand ou 40 ans on
n'ira pas là mais par contre pour ceux
qui ont déjà contracté une hypothèque si
on la difficulté ou le moment du
renouvellement on va probablement offrir
des chalonner mais comme vous l'avez dit
c'est pas loin de 30% maintenant des
nouveaux prêts pot d'écart qu'on offre
déjà pour des 30 donc on peut pas aller
beaucoup plus haut que ça parce qu'à ce
moment-là on rend pas service vraiment
aux gens et on augmente plus les taux
d'intérêt selon vous à la Banque du
Canada écoutez Géral j'ai pas de boule
de cristal mais ça prendrait vraiment
des mauvaises choses sur l'inflation une
réaccélération de l'inflation et surtout
des attentes inflationnistes pour que la
bande du Canada se mettre à augmenter et
taux d'intérêt vous savez il y a des
délais de transmission d'une hausse de
taux d'intérêt au Canada le délai de
transmission est normalement plus rapide
qu'aux États-Unis mais parce que des
gens qui ont opté pour des hypothèques
taux variables paiement fixe ce n'est
que lorsque on renouvelle l'hypothèque
que là on se fait frapper donc je pense
que la banque va se montrer patiente oui
le dernier chiffre était décevant sur
l'inflation un mois fait pas une
tendance mais je pourrais éviter une
récession sévère je du Canada va y aller
vous rester sur les lignes de côté pour
un certain moment et la Banque du Canada
dit que les institutions financières du
Canada ne sont pas immunisées le contre
toutes les certitudes bancaires qu'on
connaît du côté américain ça veut dire
quoi exactement mais gardons l'esprit
que les banques canadiennes sont doivent
se commande doit se financer sur les
marchés de capitaux donc quand les
marchés de capitaux sont relativement
tranquilles ou je dirais le pas trop
volatile ça crée pas trop problème mais
si jamais le coût d'emprunt se mettait à
augmenter d'une façon importante et de
la volatilité à ce moment-là on aurait
plus de difficultés au niveau des
banques mais ils sont très bien
capitalisés là il y a pas lieu de
paniquer mais pour les banques
canadiennes ils sont plus dépendants des
marchés du capitaux du financement en
gros qu'on appelle que les banques
américaines donc c'est à surveiller
c'est plutôt au niveau des marchés
capitaux du côté de Wall Street et la
volatilité qui pourrait affecter les
banques canadiennes mais on rassure les
gens ils sont beaucoup mieux capitalisés
des banques canadiennes donc c'est un
facteur de risque à surveiller je dirais
Clément Gignac merci comme d'habitude
bonne analyse merci à la prochaine au
plaisir bonne soirée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]